hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
unfortunately
i have a message okay my message is to
teach financial freedom is to teach
people to become wealthy
to teach people not to rely on the
system not to rely on the government
how to become financially independent
financially literate that's my message
youtube have given me a strike and i've
been banned
i've been banned from posting on youtube
i did predict this
i've been saying this actually for the
last year this has been happening for
the last year
and the reason for this video is just to
inform my followers and my viewers
what's going on because it's looking
very likely that in the next
i don't know exactly how long but very
very very soon i'm suddenly going to be
able to stop
uploading any videos and that's going to
be for at least a week i've had a
strike on youtube had a warning before
now they've just given me a strike
and listen i've got my own personal
views on why this is happening
and i guess that doesn't matter you can
make up your own mind you can do your
own research and use your
own critical thinking but the real
reason for the video is just to say if i
disappear off youtube all of a sudden if
i start disappearing
it's not that i'm not speaking i am
speaking it's just that i'm being
um you know d platformed so
i'll tell you what happened i'll set a
bit of context and i'll give the reason
why youtube have
given me a strike which by the way i am
appealing because i think that it's
crazy i just think that
i'll tell you may have seen the video
you've probably seen the video
that got me this strike so firstly
the media tried they the media did out
and out try and destroy my business and
my reputation
okay january this year um
for about six months they came after me
heavy heavy heavy heavy heavy
and at the time i was saying they're all
linked this is something bigger this is
not
and and i just sounded like a crazy
person saying this i have evidence of
this there's some only so much i can say
on youtube unless i get another strike
and they permanently delete my
uh my channel but the media were really
trying to get me and they were trying to
destroy my credibility and what they
were saying was they were saying my
techniques of property don't work
they were trying to imply with the power
of suggestion and innuendo
that i'm not who i say i am that my
students aren't successful that i'm not
really a multi-millionaire they didn't
say it
because that would have been a lie and
they would have been sued so instead
they tried to imply it
and you know i fought the media back and
you know bbc retracted
um their comments at least some of them
channel four removed their show from
catch up
and uh i didn't quite get an apology out
of them but usually what happens though
like the sun newspaper
they printed a big long um lie about me
about the whole lord sugar thing and i
responded with evidence
um and then they they they just amended
the story you know you know the whole
thing they'll put it on page two but
then they'll put a little apology on
page 37
type syndrome so i had a lot of
challenges with the media
and it really i felt like was coming
from a dark place
because and i was proving everything
that i was saying and i did
i proved actually my techniques work i
am a
multi-millionaire i started from nothing
i have every week i have success
students on my channel
and i really proved with hard evidence
and facts and none of the journalists
would come and interview me they
wouldn't come and speak to me they
wouldn't have a debate with me
they wouldn't do anything what they
wanted to do is they wanted to just look
at all of my video footage
come to my events and take little bits
out of context and write a story
with a false headline so that was
happening i think most people would have
probably if they were me would have quit
at that point
but i continued putting out content i
continued doing what i'm doing i
continued teaching people i continued
having a winner wednesday every single
week on my channel
continued um selling out large rooms
and and teaching people and uh and
that's that
not taking a salary from my training
company not you know no
weird agenda on my end very clear very
transparent
so that's the bow that i had now
while that was happening they were
trying to discredit what i was saying
they didn't manage to take me down so
now what's happening and i predicted
this would happen
is that they're finding other petty
little reasons nothing to do with me
nothing to do with property nothing to
do with financial freedom let's do what
i teach
but they're trying to get my channel
de-platformed in other ways so i did an
interview with grant cardone
um and and we spoke about i don't even
know what i can say
i'm without this video getting whacked
because the video was taken down
but basically we talked about the global
i don't even know what words i can use
the situation that's happening right now
okay
across the world the crisis we talked
about that
and what the economic
agenda i'm so scared i'm so
scared i can't even speak freely right
now but we talked about the
reasoning behind the economic reasoning
why
certain things might be happening and
taking place i mean grand cotton
discussed this he gave his opinion i
also put uh robert kiyosaki
um on i've interviewed robert kiyosaki
before but i took something
from what he said and put it on the
channel and and it was really just a
case of
look this is kind of what's happening
the rich are gonna get richer the poor
are going to get poorer
and here's how you can be independent
financially it was a financial video
it wasn't about uh you know or anything
like that
it wasn't about health it was about
finances
and it was about how we can be
independent financially it was about
capitalism it was about business it was
about investments that was it
now i did do a video with my dad my dad
went to brazil and he said the reason he
was moving to brazil was a um
because of some of the things and the
restrictions that were happening and i
interviewed my dad about that
and he shared his opinions and that
video got removed off youtube and i
received a warning
but then they found a video i did with
grant cardone
from april april
and they just suddenly flagged it now it
seems to me and listen again
people are gonna be some of the viewers
on this channel and it's gonna be like
samuel you're crazy
you think everyone's against you i don't
think everyone's against me
what i think is when you are teaching
against what the narrative is
when you're teaching against the the the
plan of the
work 40 years to retire and 40 of what
you couldn't afford to live on in the
first place
after working 40 hours a week the 40 40
40 scam
okay the um all the icers
and the help to buy schemes and all the
things that they put to you
and when i'm saying actually no and i'm
running large events
and there's a shift and it's okay it's a
coincidence right that
a week or so before my crash course you
know i start talking about my crash
course
and i'm saying hey i'm going to be
running a property investors crash
course it's free
and i'm going to teach you how to become
financially independent
i'm going to be teaching you how to and
again i have to be really careful
what i say even on this video maybe even
what i've said is too much i don't know
because the video if you saw the video
that i did with grant cardone
it was there was nothing serious during
the interview there was nothing
conspiracy it was just an interview
about wealth we just
how they're redistributing wealth and
how the rich are going to get richer and
the poor are going to get poorer
and how to be on the side of the wealthy
that was what the video is about
and then i get a strike for it so i'm
appealing the strike
but it's a coincidence that suddenly
they're going to stop me posting videos
in the run-up to my crash course i don't
think they want people at the property
investors crash course
i don't think they want you there
because i'll believe me i'll talk freely
at the property investors crash course
so i have to make an executive business
decision right now
am i am i gonna continue talking
what i think and free on social media
or am i gonna have to stop and
i don't i haven't decided how i'm gonna
play this to be honest i don't know what
i'm gonna do
because it's not even like i'm talking
about things i don't know anything about
i'm talking about the health side of
things i'm not
i'm talking about the business i'm
talking about the economic
situation i have to be so careful what i
say on this video
so anyway it's really messed up i do
think freedom of speech is gone
it's so funny that people can people can
say all kinds of
horrible things online horrible things
online but then as soon as
as soon as you start talking about
deeper things
you know things about how to get wealthy
and how to be independent from the
government
and what the agenda what the big agendas
are going on
suddenly it just disappears so
anyway if i stop posting i'm i'm
disappointed to have to post this video
it's a wednesday wednesday for me is
celebration day
i like to celebrate on a wednesday so
when i woke up this morning
to this uh it was really disappointing
and i'm going to be posting
i'll i'll try and refine the video that
got banned i'm going to post it on
instagram so if you want to
see the video that got banned then maybe
on in the description i'm going to leave
my instagram and go down to instagram
before it gets removed from instagram
um so anyway i guess this video is just
a way of me saying if i disappear
off of youtube it's not because i've
decided to stop posting it's because
i've been forced to stop posting
um i am going to have to have to really
be careful what i say
i'm not going to be careful at my events
believe me and that's why i run the
events
you know people say you can learn
everything online for free you can't
because everything's getting taken down
and this isn't just for me this is from
robert kiyosaki
brian rose from london rio oh my
goodness he's been here
i don't know him personally um i know
grant cardone very well personally
my conversation with him gets taken down
just very very strange
he's very very sad i am going to be
celebrating tonight i'll find something
to celebrate tonight we've got a winners
on a wednesday interview
if it's allowed to go up at the time of
recording this i don't even know if i'm
about to post this up
because by the time i go to post it it
might say i can't post it so it's really
interesting times
but what my advice to you i urge you
listening
to study money because
the per the people who have the money
are the people that have control and i
think that is what they're trying to
make difficult
they're trying to difficult and there is
there is massive opportunity and through
the next few years
people are going to become very very
wealthy but that information is going to
be hidden
from the majority of people so i'm not
saying i know everything about
everything my goodness
i'm 29. i'm working class guy
i grew up with nothing but i studied
rich people
i rubbed shoulders as business people i
copied what they did i learned the
formulas and it worked
and i'm living proof of that and then i
teach that at my events i teach the same
formulas
and and that's why 90 of my students
are overwhelmingly happy and recommend
their friends to do the same training
and that's why every single week i have
students
queueing up to come on my channel to
share their story of how my formulas
that i learned have changed their
financial
life so really weird time
let me know your thoughts in the
comments comment below and as i say
you know you might think right now sam
was crazy
he's crazy in 12 months time
you'll realize that i'm actually not
crazy i'm actually just
i've got i've got a message it's
something that works for me
it works for my students but i just
can't share that
on platforms so anyway guys
i hope to see you at the crash course as
well i'll be talking completely openly
at the property investors crash course
it's a pound booking fee it's a free
program it's two days i'll leave a
description
i'll leave the link in the description i
hope to see you there and
just pray for me man pray for me and
i'll pray for you
um because we're in strange times we are
in strange times i'm going to keep
teaching
even if i can't do it on youtube i'm
going to keep teaching events
in my own rooms uh jeez even if i've got
to bring people down to my house
i have done that i've done that over the
pandemic
period i've just brought people to my
house sat around this table
and taught people because this
you know the teachings that i received
have changed my life
and as a result of all what's happening
a million people losing
their jobs a job right now is one of the
riskiest places to be
and as a result of all that there are
people that will be able to be
self-sufficient entrepreneurs and the
property market by the way is booming
right now and
the rules that are changing are all
going to help the very rich and all i'm
saying is
let's learn them and let's join them um
but there's a lot of powerful people
that don't like that being said so
see you at the property investors crash
course the link
has got the so the description's got the
link and uh
i wish you all the very best to your
financial freedom thanks